all elite wrestling is gonna bring a
whole new style and a whole new flair to
what wrestling is to our weekly matches
of all elite wrestling dynamite are
going to begin airing on TNT live at
8:00 Eastern Time each Wednesday
starting October 2nd matches are going
to take place in different cities each
week on Wednesday starting into
Washington DC brought to you by somebody
who's not only in the ring but is in the
front office as the executive vice
president of all elite wrestling Cody
Rhodes good to see you sir oh thanks for
having me what a exciting time to be a
wrestler and a wrestling fan it's just
not 96 well let's before we get into it
what's your first wrestling memory ooh
some because my dad was a professional
wrestler and when he he's a Hall of
Famer Hall of Famers Yeah right when he
when he brought me to my first matches
he has kind of passed his career he was
on the executive side of things himself
and I only knew the guys like sting and
the guys who I was there to see and he
brought me backstage thinking I would
want to be part of it but when I heard
the first bump in the ring and the crowd
react I never I never wanted to be
backstage again I didn't care for it at
all I wanted to be out there mm-hmm see
it was a Brad Armstrong match in
Savannah Georgia and was in my blood
after that so you remember the first
metal match you you were brought to by
your dad oh yeah and so because there
was no youtube back then how did you
learn about your father's hall-of-fame
wrestling resume I found in our guest
bedroom my parents house I found this
kind of chest of huge reels and this is
you know VHS was pretty big at the time
sure and they were trying to put a lot
of VHS stuff out however a lot of stuff
my dad was in was rather violent and
bloody so it was hidden from me but I
found it and I dove right in and I
watched everything I wish I was
genuinely shocked because I was eight or
nine years old I had no clue you had no
idea no I didn't know he was I didn't
know he was as significant in our
industry as a wrestler until I saw that
and then I
couldn't he was he was my favorite after
that I would get no fight with anybody
over it he's my favorite okay
did you ever have any other wrestling
royalty just over at the house for
dinner or anything like oh yeah there's
a give me a good dinner story here what
you got for me it may kill a great deal
of the mystery but it's worth it's the
greatest one of all time okay hosted an
entire Thanksgiving with the four
horsemen and this isn't long after I
think they had broken Dusty's leg but
there's just there's a video of me
there's a video of me in like a little
car under the table just pushing myself
past Arn Anderson's big leg and Ric
Flair there at the end of the table so
yeah we uh we always had folks over it
was it was wild to see guys like the
road warriors and the stinger and
bossman there's just a nuts child it's
just walking around so you're a Tod
you're like riding in a car on Ric Flair
so so like so they broke your dad's leg
and he's like come on over you have some
have some he always have some turkey or
no he always explained it to me in a way
that I I didn't mind I liked being
disillusioned by it all in his simple
ways of putting it to me always okay how
that make sense
like he explained that you couldn't
fight outside of the ring otherwise the
league which the vague league would find
you or there would be these big
repercussions and I had a young age I
bought it like oh yeah hey that makes
sense and then the same as we got older
I'd see guys bust a wooden chair over
his head and then shake his hand later
and he'd say well you know respect back
here out there yeah it's the only place
we can truly compete and I never once
did I question it never once I didn't
want a question it shows to - dang fun
yah was the son of a French teacher
coming and I just remember the first
time he took me in the class and I saw
behind the lesson plan and I was just
whoa thought all the kids of Spanish
teachers you know you want to start my
dad is you know he was older he was a
vice
principal he was a college advisor do
you speak French umpah there you go
there you go there it's a little a
little so do you still see Ric Flair
some of the old the oh jeez oh yeah I
try really hard with with what we do now
we just had four all out in Chicago
both Tully Blanchard and Arn Anderson
were involved but I try to really
sprinkle it in in the best possible way
when you have some nostalgia yes because
it's so important that we push forward
the new class and the new roster of
talent because wrestling for a long time
is like heavily reliant on let's bring
on this legend let's bring on this you
know veteran and in this case I try to
just sprinkle men like Arn came down and
just hit a wicked spinebuster and the
entire Searson er went nuts and that was
all he needed to do you know so I try to
keep it involved because for me I can
never I can't be a character it's it's
my character is who I really am I'm a
really dusty son and I grew up in the
business and I can't really pretend to
be anything else so for me it fits into
a lot of my matches Cody Rhodes here on
the rich guys to show them let us talk
about the here and now and how it came
to that so when you said you're not a
character you are who you are is that
why you and WWE left and you wanted to
do your own thing I mean why did you
want to do your own thing here what I
had I had poof eleven years and that
schedule was pretty grueling you know
Friday Saturday Sunday Monday Tuesday I
never missed a live event I just felt I
felt like there was a bigger picture for
me I felt like I could do more I'd felt
like I'd paid my dues and I started
there when I was 20 years old and they
still kind of treated me like I was
still 20 years old so I just wanted to
take the education I got from him take
the education I got from my dad and go
be something else I didn't want to be
like I said I didn't want to be another
character I wanted to be this like
combination of everything I had built
all that equity had had growing up on TV
mm-hmm and that was the first steps I
took hit the independent scene and the
independent scene was thriving and the
alternative brands like New Japan Pro
Wrestling and Ring of Honor we're doing
really well
linked up with some other non
WWE backed wrestling talent and that's
ultimately what led to kind of the slow
formation of oh I think we could
actually have an alternative product
well I mean it's so difficult to have an
alternative product when the product is
already branded in such a way for
decades how many people told you to
forget it
oh I mean an endless amount of people
told me to forget it but the one who I
love proving wrong the most is my lovely
mother my lovely mother who is terrified
of this leap of faith when every time we
sell out a show like for the first
dynamite episode it's Capital One
Washington DC massive arena sold right
out those are the shows I like her to be
at so she can see like you told you soda
your mom you know I got it I feel like
this is the soprano but interestingly
enough they were about everyone was
probably telling you did Vince do you
ever speak to Vince about this at all or
no no obviously not about the
alternative like it didn't come to me so
much as what happened was there were
four major free agents in wrestling it
was myself kenny omega and the young
bucks and tony kahn yes of we were just
talking about the Jags i know tony tony
kahn who's a die-hard wrestling consumer
and and fan and just really smart to our
industry was the one who said i can get
this i can back you guys fully and be
accountable you can hold me accountable
and I'll hold you guys accountable and I
can get this on TNT and he wasn't lying
he the day we signed the day our free
agency began was that the day it really
ended you know and he took us under his
wing and everything's gone forward sense
and every day something news been just
amazing like the trucks the production
trucks with all our pictures and imagery
on them like you said WWE has been this
big massive brand for almost 20 years
but wrestling's been around since the
turn of the century so it's great that
there's an another option especially for
wrestlers who want healthier schedules
or better pay or just another option to
know that there's not just one place how
did you go to hooked
with the Khan family again Schad Khan
owner of the Jaguars Tony's his son
who's in the Jaguars front office the
president and CEO and founder of aew
how'd you get hooked up with the Khan
family so Tony is a big wrestling fan I
had seen him before
Staples Center backstage at various
shows and always somebody that I liked
talking to because he had a good grip on
like what what wrestling might be good
today you know these guys were getting
really popular I saw this guy in Japan I
saw this girl on an independent he had a
really good mind for what may be the
future of things would be but it wasn't
until that free agency when I actually
didn't even take the first call I didn't
think it was real hmm I didn't he really
was serious about the endeavor a startup
wrestling company to compete with the
juggernaut that his WWE but he was he
was serious about it and Matt Jackson of
the young bucks took that call and I
came to a Jags game and as he was
vetting me I kind of got a vet him cuz
to see how he runs that organization
amongst these giant NFL larger-than-life
characters and I was really just
impressed with him overall especially as
a manager and leader he's a lot
different than the management style I
was used to and since then we've been
buds plus we like Star Trek we love we
love I don't know if folks in the house
oh yeah I mean I wouldn't call myself a
Trekkie but I mean I'm more of the
old-school out of the next generation
I'm of the of the William Shatner
Captain Kirk Spock series yes I like it
I don't feel like you like it I don't
like it as much okay mm-hmm when it
comes to that mm-hmm okay
not even Picard the guard is the number
one I think hold on a second
Cody Rhodes here on the Richards you
because I know where we're treading into
turf pop-culture turf that that that
there's this is an argument based share
a turf you're number one captain in the
history of Star Trek is it kept in
Picard by far why is that
well I maybe I look at it from a
production standpoint as far as when TNG
hit the
hit TV yes they were the king of cable
so much so that they had three different
I mean Deep Space nine came out at the
same time and Voyager at one point there
were three different tracks on TV and it
all stems back to Patrick Stewart as
Picard was returning yes to the role I
don't I loved William Shatner I do okay
I just want to make sure so I love but
cuz you know without William Shatner ya
emoting in the manner when she used to
emote whether it was a Tribble with with
with whom he had trouble or the original
you you know before there was shod con
there was the wrath there was okay
understand but McArdle Montalban and
they made Star Trek to one of the
greatest the greatest Star Trek movie
are you into the old starch 100% wrath
of Wrath honest is the number one Star
Trek movie 100% I just want them okay
you you agree with that
I actually the original series cast in
the movies
amazing love it love it I don't think
the next-generation cast and the movies
did it as much justice as they did so
you so would Tony agree with your
assessment he's like you he's an
original series guy yeah okay I'm moving
I don't know I like cuz again what
you're doing with aew mm-hm and it's
going gangbusters again on TNT every
single Wednesday night starting on
October the second to our weekly matches
all elite wrestling dynamite without
that without that that doesn't happen I
guess without you know the Dusty Rhodes
era oh yeah paving the way
oh they're kind of I'm just saying that
there's the old school you understand
that gotta respect it gotta respect it
ya know so it's a card and then Kirk or
even you kicking him down Kirk is three
Picard Janeway Kirk Sisko Archer Wow
even a Pike is moving up because like
well Hampton Pike on the new Discovery
Series ants and the guy who plays them I
don't know if anyone's watching a pike
is killing it our core Trekkie I'm
looking for the forward to the Picard
reboot that looks amazing yeah it looks
great amazing coming up soon 7m9 coming
back you go that's big you're real man
this is great
and I would be remiss if I did not
mention the fact that you married
completely up and I had absolutely no
idea that your your your bride whose
deep involved with the aew as well
brandy Rhodes who was here on the set
went to the great University of Michigan
I had no idea about that yes full
academic ride as she will so often tell
you okay and she is just the best thing
there she is the best thing on earth
right just Whitney she's getting
involved in a lot of my matches chief
brand officer for the promotion she's
done some really great stuff already -
she hooked up aw with culture city which
makes us the very first sensory
inclusive wrestling company for
invisible illnesses PTSD autism to
provide a space for them to come to the
show without feeling anxious or worried
and that bad partnership all forged by
that lovely woman right there fantastic
- the best and you know you do realize
that LeBron's Springhill entertainment
they reached out to a Michigan person to
help run that okay yeah the New England
Patriots their dynasty does not exist
merely does not exist without that
Michigan Wolverines share Tom Brady
you've done well sir thank you thank you
smart move only the most successful
organizations turn to a wolverine and
Brandi and I will not talk a bit about
the football program right now it's okay
it's okay but congratulations and so a
family affair you've put this all
together and it's blowing up yeah it's
obviously lots work to be done sure and
and and you've got to keep on with each
week putting a fresh coat of paint as I
like to call every single show that we
do here we're turning five here in a
couple weeks it's a fresh coat of paint
and and it's an important business to
just keep on keepin on but
congratulations on the way it's all
turning out congratulations for five no
I shouldn't have said that it's not
about me even though there is an
iron-rich and Eisen in the name of the
show is named after me but
congratulations on what you've you've
been building and thank you and we're
part
same family here on TNT were on in that
night that is I speaking of family that
little video that ran always makes me
laugh on the inside because at the very
end is me hugging my brother and he's
covered in blood after I just beat him
up and everyone everyone thinks it's
like this nice like emotional moment I
just keep looking at it like oh poor
Dustin I mean I think we all just
assumed that that's the way the Rhodes
family goes about it but that is a
hundred percent the cathartic way of
exercise that's why people don't bat an
eyelash right give it Kody I mean I'm
sure if you just don't we don't even
notice any difference but do you have a
football team other than Jaguars are
they they have to be your football team
so or up you go you're a Georgia guy or
Georgia guy but if you're truly from
Georgia and Lana's not the hottest
sports city okay but the team you can
always root for are the Bulldogs as far
as college is concerned right it's I got
a weird selection I love I love the
Bulldogs when it comes to pro football
I'm a hundred percent on board Duval
County with the Jags my sister did cheer
for the Dallas Cowboys though so I have
to did she really Cajun aliy get in a
cowhand mode what a family my brother's
a lawyer my dad's a yeah yeah French
teacher we have a wonderful family I'm
thrilled to be part of the family but my
gosh yeah you're doing a reality show to
or what maybe maybe
branding it's all brand new okay live -
ow
I'll our weekly matches of all elite
wrestling dynamite again it's gonna
begin airing on TNT live 8:00 Eastern
every Wednesday starting the second of
October by the way which is the birthday
of the Afro mentioned French teacher my
dad happy birthday that's right happy
birthday in the ass 82 matches are gonna
take place in different cities each week
you so you got Boston Philly Pittsburgh
Charleston West Virginia Charlotte
Nashville Indy Chicago and more yeah
we're gonna working our way down the
eastern seaboard and then across a lot
of the West Coast folks don't understand
the logistic truck tour yeah so we're
getting there
okay I'm trying real hard we're
obviously we're getting there and are we
gonna see Gardner Minshew and anything's
we have to he's made for pro wrestling
don't you think half - I had a great
mustache at one point say it was
actually I got a an action figure for
that
more exclusive here is it all look at
that outfit the quarterback of the
Jacksonville Jaguars right there but
though you want your quarterback to look
like that a million percent I would
choose that as Cody was staying in a
great mustache his wife was no that was
shaking her head no yeah I had to get
rid of it for the wedding we didn't even
let they become a storyline thing I had
to just literally just showed up and hey
man I had a moustache shirt that's good
that's the facial hair that I have has
been wife approved she added that's
number one number two after I moved in
with my wife all of my belongings just
gone poof everything except for one
chair I got to keep one chair that's it
and then everything else when I got this
show knock on wood five years ago and
there and I told her hey you know
DirecTV would like to have all of my you
know stuff that's about me on the set
she's like great all these things that I
want out of the house put them in the
soil Wow number of times I get somebody
somebody gives me something she goes you
know what that'd be good for great on
the set I'm Sonia I hide all my
memorabilia wife is sitting right here
well no I mean she knows because it
shows she'll screw it she'll do stomp on
it or something so I try to put it
somewhere you know
so as you again once again all elite
wrestling Dynamite's gonna be on TNT you
heard keep an eye peeled for Gardner
Minshew
and Jalen Ramsey will do it thanks for
coming on Co Hugh so mad at Cody Rhodes
on Twitter at American Nightmare Cody on
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app